i love this guy and i'm not just saying
because he's on hold hearing me
introduce him
as uh the all-pro pro bowl tight end of
the san francisco 49ers and one of the
three
i guess uh emeritus professors of tight
end university or deans of tainan
university i guess
um george kettle joining me here on the
rich island show how are you george
rich thanks for the intro man i'm
excited to be back you know just my
favorite talk show
i appreciate that just just happy to be
able to have a conversation with you
today
how are you today feel the same way what
what are what are you travis kelsey and
and and greg olsen are you the deans of
tight end
university what are you the provosts
what we call you you know
i think we're just a part of it man and
you know we're all just tight ends
trying to hang out and get better and
learn from each other you know we might
be the ones that are trying to
orchestrate it but at the end of the day
you know we're just tight ends trying to
hang out with other tight ends
june 23rd through 25th in the great city
of nashville tennessee right
i got that right that's it oh please i
mean it was
i know that's where you spend uh your
off season time right george you
you got a spot in nashville it is uh
yeah i moved to nashville right after my
rookie year
just kind of fell in love with it and uh
bought some nice uh acreage you know
outside of nashville last year and
i've just been a huge fan of it and uh
you know what a better place to hang out
with uh you know
a bunch of tight ends than nashville
tennessee got plenty of dude on there
from football to uh
you know being able to hang out so it's
it's going to be a good time down there
we're excited about it i love it why why
do it where'd this come from
all right so really for me is i think
that all tight ends you know i think we
should all be friends because you know
it's it's it's one position on a
football field you know sometimes two
you got sometimes three on you know goal
line stuff but you're
it's usually one guy out there that's
the only guy that takes the snaps and
i feel like you know out of the 32 teams
while they have two or three guys active
like
i feel like the tight ends need to hang
out more i need to learn from each other
more and so
i saw the d-line has a summit the the
o-line does the summit where they all
come together they all learn from each
other and i was like why
there's a holiday why isn't there a
tight end summit where we can all come
together and learn from each other
because
you know in my opinion the title
position is incredibly difficult because
you have to
run routes you have to catch passes you
have to block defensive ends you have to
insert on linebackers you have to pass
pro defensive ends like
you kind of have to do everything um and
so why not have uh you know
a little time where we can all come
together and you know learn from the
best of the best and you know just learn
from tight ends all over the country and
so
i'm excited that you know we kind of got
the ball rolling on it um
you know had to get you know kelsey
involved had to get you know greg olsen
involved and you know they've been
incredibly helpful and you know just
throwing ideas around but you know we're
really really excited about you know
getting the first one
you know down this summer and uh when
you know people might be confused
they shouldn't be but let's let's let's
give them a less confusion
when you refer to george kittle a
national holiday
you're referring to national tight ends
day that happens once a year every year
during the football season
correct that's right for me it's every
day but yeah for other people i guess
it's just once
my children always say that on mother's
day or father's day what about
children's day i'm like every day is
children's day are you kidding me
every day you know i get it every day is
national tight end day though but
you know like rich we're really excited
about it too and we really wanted to
you know put on a really good event for
everybody so we got involved some
sponsors that are allowing us to really
make this like a nice ordeal really take
care of guys
you know put them up um take care of
them have some fun while we're down
and you know in nashville and you know
from you know bud light to charmin
levi's like we got these like companies
coming in to step
up that are you know they're donated for
tight and you but at the end of the day
it's also fun because we're gonna donate
basically every every amount of money
that we don't spend on basically hotel
rooms for the tight ends is going to uh
charities and love it
um and bridgestone is a huge part of
that as well and so the fact that
you know we can raise money for charity
and i can get you know tight ends that
come down to nashville and we can learn
from each other it's it's pretty awesome
because
at the start of the day we we banked
them like hey maybe we can get like 15
to 20 guys and
we have over 40 guys that have rsvp'd
and
it's uh way more than what we thought
we're going to get and i'm just really
excited about it because you know i have
an opportunity to learn from 40 other
guys about the tight end position so
that's that's uh 40. that's a lot of
that's a lot of toilet paper that's a
lot of charmin
isn't a lot of tight ends yeah yeah is
that is that the connection here for
charmin and tight ends
i'm gonna let sharman make that
connection
i just don't know if the agenda goes
from front to back or back to front
you know i just don't you know what i
mean george they're rich
rich went there not me and i should be
i should be the more studious one that
is correct but you know okay george
um so let's uh let's get into the 40 uh
is it true one of the 40 that's coming
is tim tebow did tim get the invite
to you know um i'm not sure if he's
gotten the invite
um it's like i said we we banked on
getting 20 guys
rich and we've had 40 that have rsvp'd
and so
um and like i said we're working with
sponsors so we can pay for guys to come
in and
take care of everybody and so we're
working on a numbers thing like i said
we're about 20 over what we thought we
were going to get
so it's more of a we're trying to figure
out how we can include everybody and
the fact that this is year one um i
we're gonna redo what we can with the
guys that we have but you know hopefully
in the next coming years that you know
tied in summit keeps happening
right that we can make it open to the
entire nfl because
you know it hurts me to not be able to
invite you know every single tight end
that's on nfl rosters guys that aren't
on rosters because
i think you haven't you have an
opportunity to learn from every single
person that you know is invited so
we're working on it we're trying like
like i said we're trying to get
everybody to be able to come in the
coming years and
um we're almost there uh you know i
gotta i gotta
i guess i gotta get tim's number give
him a call but you know hey gronk called
back about it so i'm excited that he
might be in it
um because i would love to sit in a room
and you know watch him with that guy
well o.j howard is
is coming from from from the buccaneers
as well
i mean just it's a heck of a list that
you've got going on
right here um george kittle so uh do you
need somebody
to film maybe a welcome video or
something
or wow rich you're offering you know
just set up like hey welcome to the
tight end summit this is what you're
going to learn today yes
oh you know that's not a bad idea you
can just text me on the side about that
so we don't you know give away our tips
and all of our information to all of the
listeners out there i'd be more than
happy to do that
george like to give like set the agenda
for the day or something like that or
you know
if there's a a word of the day or
something like oh
we can workshop this thing i'd be more
than happy to be part of this you know
um yeah you know like i you know i came
up to
indianapolis and i think you can come
down to nashville i think i could show
you a good time down there rich
well you know i i i live all the way out
here
uh in los angeles george and on top of
it the middle day of
national of the tight ends university is
my birthday
i turned 52 in the middle of all that
what better place to celebrate than
nashville tennessee
now you're talking george yeah now
you're talking
let's go i don't know is there anything
to do there no broadway there's nothing
on broadway there's nothing to do
is there anything to eat there i don't
know a good restaurant i don't know a
drink
i've got a couple places
it could be interesting i couldn't
imagine a better group of people that
i'd want to spend my birthday with
you mean us right no i don't think nfl
tight ends yes
i honestly don't know of a better group
maybe you know maybe a group of
offensive linemen but
we're pretty close well i mean seriously
i mean you're practically you
practically
on the line well you are on the line i
mean thank you i was just gonna let you
say it i don't know
i mean you're you're right there anyway
okay all right well we'll workshop that
thing
uh i've got uh george i appreciate that
of course i've got george kittle here on
the rich eisen show another one of the
tight ends at titan university is your
buddy big bobby tanyan
he'll be there as well right about him
yeah i know you by the way when you
referred to being in indianapolis at my
run
in 2020 this is before last year you
brought him
and you're like watch out for this guy
is what you said to me before that
season where he just went
off the charts incredibly watch out you
did
you did people are going to learn at
some point man okay is he nervous about
who's throwing the ball to him
this summer i know what the great thing
about being a tight end is all you have
to do is focus on your job because
there's just so much going on
with every single play that's right i
bet you i bet you it's helpful when he
has aaron rodgers throwing in the ball
but
you know at the end of the day titans
you know we're gritty and we just get
down in the mud and you know he's going
to enjoy playing in the cold and he's
just going to catch footballs and
he's probably going to have more
touchdowns again next year i guess you
should speak for yourself rather than
your friend um put you in that position
so let me get let me get to that first
things first
uh george kittle not only am i always
thrilled to talk to you
um but also talk to you about your tight
end university which is important to you
but also to just make sure that you are
alive um on a sunday and i'm assuming
now that you're alive on a wednesday
based on what uh you know is the general
i guess
uh 49er way of looking at things right
yeah
george you're alive uh i am unless this
is a recording that no one will know
that
you know it was something i got to text
kyle on sunday and i said i'm still here
you were one of the people who texted
him that sunday huh that you're still
hey rich you think i'm gonna let that
one go
i'm all over that i mean
normally your your coach will say i
can't even tell you what the weather is
you know i actually got that from arthur
smith of the falcons when i asked him
about julio jones about a month ago and
that's before all the craziness that's
gone on right oh by the way you're on
live tv right now i just should just let
you know
you know what yeah this isn't a
recording that's crazy it's not
recording and we're not you know that
we're
we're other people are hearing what
we're saying right now um but
so i i i'll just come through the the
front door here and
uh ask you about you know uh trey lance
and jimmy g
and how you see that all playing out it
seems like everything is pretty cool
for for for now if not for the
foreseeable future
george you wanna know something crazy
about the draft rich please
so i'm taking off on a plane to go uh to
my bachelor party
in uh scottsdale and during the draft my
flight took off
on the um it took off
as the third pick was announced oh my
god and so i didn't see it
until i could connect the wi-fi about 30
minutes later
so larry it goes the pick is in
and then they all cut out and i sat
there for 30 minutes like all right
this is uh i'm sweating i don't know
what's going on
[Music]
this is stressful i can't call anybody
but uh then yeah then i finally
connected the wi-fi after you know it
gets to the 10 000 feet and i was like
all right
sick cool this is going to be fun but it
was uh
yeah trey bay bay but that was uh that
was a stressful 30 minutes for me
i bet so i i bet so so
um we we had uh as you refer to him trey
beibe
on the show uh two days before the 49ers
took him
i could not have been more engaged and
impressed by
him and how you know uh
normal and um professional
he was like he nailed the bullet point
the copy points of the sponsor that
hired him to
do the tour that brought him to this
show like i love it
seriously in a way that i've had
veterans on and i would have to read the
copy points for them because i try to be
a professional and help them out
he i mean he nailed it he nailed
everything and couldn't have been
funnier
and more engaging rich i'm not gonna lie
i'm pretty sure i think you tweeted
something about that about how good he
was no
that's cool good for him like that's a i
know it's also crazy that the fact that
you just turned 21 just is kind of
mind-boggling
it is no doubt about it so have you have
you been on a practice field with him
yet or that has yet to
occur oh yeah george no i uh i got back
for the last week of phase two for otas
last week and you know i got to be on a
field with him catching passes from him
he's got a cannon um it's just fun you
know
i said it yesterday you know he looks
better than a rookie quarterback which
is fun you know
his uh i was like on his his yeah our
first live day going against the defense
on monday
hit a nice roll out a deep pass to uh my
rookie tight end josh peterson
uh he's you know it's not a throw that
gets made a lot you know and the fact
that he did on his first rollout was
pretty funny
and the fact that he completed for a
touchdown was pretty cool so then just
i'll just
ask you just straight out uh
you know because i i understand that if
you're heard to
be complimenting trey that could be
viewed by some as that that's what you
prefer
and obviously you are just on a team
where the coach is going to make the
decision
uh how how are you in between you know
with
obviously a choice at the position who's
going to have to play as soon as
possible based on
on on many circumstances that are your
control george kittle and also a guy who
went to the super bowl with who you like
genuinely so what can you tell me rich
at the end of the day they're both my
teammates so you know i'm going to be
both of their biggest tight men
um now the great thing about football is
the competition and
that competition is what breeds
greatness and that's what you know makes
you better football players so
you know if either one of my qbs or you
know we have five qb's on the ross right
now if any of the five shy away from
competition
and they don't really deserve to be on a
football field and so i'm excited about
the competition in the room i'm excited
about the competition all over our team
because
i think we're pretty deep in some areas
and so you know yeah like i said
i'm gonna hype up both you know every
single one of my teammates and if they
get offended by me hyping up my
teammates
ah there's something else that's going
on there how does bosa look how
is he looking right now because i mean
you you want to talk about a bounce back
year
if you will you were hurt for much of it
last year he was hurt for
damn near all of it the team just took
one
you know uh hit after another including
not having a home
essentially for a month i mean so you've
got to be
kind of fired up tell me how everybody
looks and
feels going into the summer prior to
what could be
a a monster return for you in the
deepest end of the nfl pool this
division
oh wait we got evicted that's like you
put it really nicely we got kicked out
that was crazy
but you know we uh you know it was
definitely interesting moving arizona
for
uh six weeks you know it was definitely
different but
same time it was fun um it would have
been more fun if i could have played in
every single game but
right yeah we did take a lot of hits but
um the fact that you know our team went
through all that stuff and
we signed i couldn't tell you how many
like free agent people we brought in
just to be able to feel the team
um and just have new faces in and out of
the building but the fact that we were
still able to keep our culture and you
know still be positive even though we
were living in arizona we're not playing
at our home
stadium and half of our team was hurt
the fact that our you know our coaches
kept it together and our the guys that
were still there playing kept it
together i was you know
very impressed and it just says a lot
about the team and you know the
the fact that we are getting everybody
back is it's very exciting um
i think i've said this about 100 times i
still think nick bose is like the second
best nfl player behind aaron donald
and i think he's going to come back with
a vengeance and i'm very excited about
that because
he's a very talented football player and
he definitely makes that defense
gear up and hold an extra notch george i
appreciate the call
i do miss uh chatting with you um send
my best to greg olson i saw what he
tweeted out about his son
um and and i i know that they um
they are just such great humans and uh i
love that guy
i'll do anything to help you out with
this tight end university seriously
um i appreciate that you know yeah and i
never met uh i've never met greg's kids
but i know
i've heard nothing but incredible things
about tj and you know we're all
you know supporting him and sending him
every single positive vibe and all the
good energy that we can for
you know that to be uh as successful as
it can be
so we're just praying for him and uh but
you know greg's been an
absolute champ too the amount of work
that he's put into this when he has
every right to completely not talk about
it or talk to us but he's been
incredible so
nothing but all good things for them
exactly right but seriously i'll do a
video i i've done many of them in my
career uh george i haven't really seen
anything i might have to get some tapes
i'll send you a few links i'll send you
a couple youtube links okay yeah
no send me your huddle link man
i'll do that uh but i also could like
it's up to you like if you want me to
roast the room
and work blue and if you think it that
works for you
i'll do that i've done that for fantasy
leagues of people i've done
i've done lots of stuff so i'll go
anywhere you'd like
for this i'm gonna be part of that i'm
gonna i'll see i'll see travis
uh next weekend oh yes and uh you know
we'll go over some of the things that
maybe you can do for us
i'd love that you're offering all your
services i am the whole the whole scope
of services
uh but i'll leave the course that's it
that's exactly
i'll just leave the uh the curriculum up
to you though that's your choice
okay you know what to do i'm excited
about this maybe doing some rich eyes
and trivia
we'll figure it out i love it george you
take care best of your dad best of the
whole kittle team
appreciate that oh i appreciate that
rich he's probably listening right now
he probably says hi
fantastic probably what the hell
probably you never know man
[Music]
take care of yourself george you're the
best man see you guys you guys george
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here